hello in this video we'll talk about
myoglobin versus hemoglobin now
hemoglobin
and myoglobin are both globular proteins
and
both of them binds to oxygen however
they have several differences in terms
of structure
and function in this video we would
explore all of that so stay tuned till
the end of this video
hemoglobin has four subunits and
myoglobin has only one
that means hemoglobin is far more
complicated
from a structural point of view
myoglobin
has 153 amino acids whereas
alpha subunit of hemoglobin has 141
amino acids
and beta subunit has 146 amino acids
now myoglobin is generally found in the
muscles
especially the skeletal muscles and the
cardiac muscles
hemoglobin is generally found in the
rbcs
in the blood right generally we don't
find myoglobin
in the blood and in rare cases
there could be severe muscle injury when
myoglobin
leaks out into the blood and it can also
be found into the urine and that
situation is known as rhabdomyolysis so
myoglobin
myoglobin's presence in the blood could
be
indicative of this kind of pathological
situation
now myoglobin and hemoglobin can both
bind to oxygen but myoglobin's binding
affinity
is way more and that makes myoglobin
a oxygen storage protein whereas
hemoglobin is a oxygen transport protein
so let's understand the binding kinetics
of
hemoglobin and myoglobin but before that
let me tell you
that the globin part which is the
protein part of these
structures are encoded by
several genes several million years ago
myoglobin gene is bifurcated
from the hemoglobin gene lineage so both
of them
are slightly different now let's talk
about
the oxygen binding kinetics and in order
to talk about that we need to understand
the 3d structure in bit more details
myoglobin has a to h helices
where in between helix e
and f the hem group reside now
the heme group
has specific interaction with histidine
residues protruding out of these
helices now this heme group
has very important roles in terms of
oxygen binding
there is one histidine group known as
distal histidine
and another histidine which is known as
proximal histidine
now the binding of oxygen causes
substantial structural
change and this structural change
means a lot in terms of hemoglobin
but not it doesn't really matter for
myoglobin at all so this
is a structure of myoglobin
and let us try to understand the oxy
versus deoxy
structure oxygenated structure of the
myoglobin
we can clearly understand or visualize
the structural change
for hemoglobin when oxygen
binds to one subunit it actually helps
the other sub unit
to get uh or to be bound with oxygen
so this kind of behavior is known as
cooperativity
in this video we will learn about the
basis of cooperativity in bit more
details
so let's talk about the binding kinetics
so in case of hemoglobin generally in a
deoxygenated state
the ferrous ion is actually elevated
from the plane now when oxygen binds
it leads to conversion of the structure
into a planar planar ring
so this kind of structural change has a
lot of
effect in terms of hemoglobin's function
so let me tell you what that
is hemoglobin
exists in two state one is
t state or taut state and in this state
hemoglobin is
deoxygenated now
it can also exist in our state
the r state is oxygenated now
in this state there are conformational
change
now between alpha and beta subunits
there could be several
there could be stacking interaction
there could be sliding interactions
so in our state the contacts between
alpha and beta subunits are
shifted whereas in the t state it's not
so now we'll try to understand the
binding
kinetics we can see the binding kinetics
of myoglobin has a michaelis-menten type
graph whereas the hemoglobin shows a
sigmoidal
curve in order to understand the basis
of this binding we have to understand
the dissociation constant or association
constant
so let us try to understand the oxygen
binding into myoglobin in form of an
equation so here mbo2
is a oxygen bound myoglobin which can be
dissociated to myoglobin and oxygen
let us try to understand k d is the
dissociation constant so k
d is given by concentration of myoglobin
multiplied by oxygen concentration
divided by
bound myoglobin concentration now we can
derive one term which is known as
fractional saturation
so fractional saturation of y is equal
to number of occupied binding sites
divided by total number of binding sites
which would be given by this expression
and now if we explain it in terms of
partial pressure
fractional saturation would come like
this
partial pressure of oxygen divided by
po2 plus
the dissociation constant and if we plot
this
it would take a sigmoid shape just like
a michaelis-menten equation
it's pretty much similar right now let's
talk about
the oxygen binding kinetics in the
hemoglobin
now here we have a protein which is our
hemoglobin
and the ligand is oxygen now
n number of ligand can bind to this
protein and form
this particular protein ligand complex
so in case of hemoglobin this n
equal to 4 now let us try to
give association constant here k
association and the reverse would be
dissociation constant
so we can clearly write the association
constant
as this kind of expression
now we can also derive the
binding fraction or saturation fraction
which would be
binding sites which are occupied divided
by
total number of binding sites and if we
do our
math we would derive an equation like
this
and by replacing it with the partial
pressure of oxygen
we would ultimate ultimately generate
another equation
so this particular equation
if we plot it in the graph it would
kind of come like a
so this particular equation if we take
log on the both side
and plot it in a graph it would show a
sigmoidal curve
so this curve is pretty much different
from michaelis-menten equation now if we
have
a value of n which is n equal to 1 then
it shows
a low affinity state whereas a value of
n equal to 3 would show
a high affinity state so let us try to
understand in bit more details what this
kind of sigmoidal curves
means in terms of hemoglobin's oxygen
binding kinetics
okay so let us try to
understand this phenomena so we can
replace
the axis the x-axis by
partial pressure of oxygen and the theta
can be simply
understood as percent saturation now let
us
try to understand we we take two phases
of this
curve one the linear and one the
non-linear or the platophase
now when we are at the path of plateau
phase when the
hemoglobin is totally saturated then we
increase
the partial pressure of oxygen but look
at the y-axis
the percent saturation really didn't
change much
but now if we take a look at the linear
phase when the hemoglobin is not
totally saturated at this particular
point let's say and at this particular
point we have
increased the partial pressure of oxygen
a little bit
but only this much but look at the y
axis
the person saturation has dramatically
increased
and so what we see the summary of it
is like with a minimal change of partial
pressure there is a huge change of
oxygen binding
into the hemoglobin and that happens due
to the
property of cooperativity if
cooperativity does not exist
we did not see this kind of we should
not see this kind of curve
now let us try to understand from a
pictorial manner
so at low at lower saturation
we have still some sites which are
accessible for oxygen binding
so that is why with a small change in
oxygen partial pressure
there would be increase in oxygen
binding to the hemoglobin
but at the plateau phase all of the
sites would be
occupied so even if we increase the
oxygen
partial pressure there would be no
oxygen binding to the hemoglobin so this
kind of
explains the basis of that sigmoidal
curve
and the cooperativity of the binding and
this also tells us that
how both the proteins bind to oxygen but
they bind to the oxygen in a different
manner the kinetics of binding is
different
so i hope that explains this video in
this video we talked about
the structural functional basis of
hemoglobin versus myoglobin how they are
different how they are similar
what are the basis of the
dissimilarities etc
so if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up and don't forget to like
share and subscribe
and do let me know in the comment how
you like my video and don't forget to
turn on the bell bell
icon for notification thank you